aoc
just took a little vacation to florida
kovid was exploding in new york
things are locked down still in many
ways so
aoc goes with her boyfriend they go to
florida
what happens
she's not wearing a mask
she's been a little loose with the rules
she gets covered
i don't think she got covered because
she went to florida i don't think she
got covered because she's not wearing a
mask
virtually all of my friends in new york
have covid right now or have recently
recovered from kovid
but she got it
she's
extremely vaccinated she's one of the
biggest peddlers of all the covid
lockdown rules
she says
she her office sends out this statement
representative ocasio-cortez has
received a positive test result for
covet-19 she's experiencing symptoms and
recovering at home the congresswoman
received her booster shot this fall and
encourages everyone to get their booster
and follow all cdc guidance
now the good news for the young healthy
aoc
is that
it doesn't matter it's like a cold
you'll be fine
but the political import here is that it
turns the consensus view on its head
the consensus view being peddled by the
establishment right now is that when
anti-vaxxers
when anti-vaxx
anti-science
meaning people who don't just want to
stick themselves with some random drug
to prevent
or
or to not prevent getting a mild cough
that they're idiots they're they're
idiots they're rubes
actually though
it seems to me
that when someone who
goes out and says look we're all going
to get covet at some point it's just for
for the vast majority of us it's not
going to be a big deal it's fine i'm
going to roll the dice when that person
gets kovid that's that's not ironic or
funny or that's
what you would expect that's what that
person would expect too
it is much
much funnier
when a person who is triple vaxxed and
wears three masks at a time and locked
themselves in a hermetically sealed tube
for two years comes down with covid
because they thought they weren't going
to get it and they kept saying it's a
pandemic of the unvaccinated and they
believed fauci and rochelle wolenski and
joe biden
like idiots they believed these people
and then it turned out that what we were
told by wallensky and fauci and biden
just wasn't true
and then they got it that's
it's never funny when someone gets
a sickness you know thankfully in this
case
you know
the vast vast majority of people are
gonna be just completely fine some won't
even know that they have it
but if you're telling me one is funnier
than the other it is much funnier when
the people
have their expectations subverted and in
this case that would be
the left hey i'll make this quick ring
the bell please that would be great ring
the bell subscribe get those
notifications
really if you want the notifications
head on over to apple podcast spotify
stitcher google play wherever you get
your audio podcasts
subscribe to the michael knowles show
leave a five star review see you next
time
[Music]
[Music]